a swearing-in ceremony for Brazil's new
health minister Nelson Teich but
president Shia bolson ro used the
occasion to defend his controversial
handling of the corona virus pandemic
not least his decision to fire his
previous health minister Luis Enrique
man detta who refused to play down the
risks of kovat 19 history will judge us
and I ask God that we are right the
struggle to start opening up for
business as a risk that I will take if
it gets worse it's on me what I believe
and what lots of people are coming to
realize is that the country has to open
up man detta wanted to implement World
Health Organization guidelines but
bolson ro opposes social distancing
measures and Etta's sacking has worried
Brazilians
it's a bad idea because the guy was
doing a good job he's a guy who
reassured the people asking them to stay
at home but he went against all senora's
opinions and so balsa narrow fire the
guy but others agree with the president
that the economy and jobs must come
first
my company closed a month ago but I'll
reopen it next Monday I have no options
I have 80 employees so we'll go forward
with respect and care more than 2000
Brazilians have died so far from the
corona virus making Brazil the worst hit
country in Latin America in its worst
affected State San Paulo the governor
extended the lockdown for another three
weeks and warned the health care system
is struggling to cope as with the easy
fear my dear the intensive care units of
public and private hospitals are
receiving a larger number of patients
each day and we already have some public
hospitals at the edge of their capacity
the president and his new Health
Minister want an end to the lockdown but
Brazil's Supreme Court says that's a
decision for state governors and city
mayors Victoria Gaytan B al Jazeera